to talk more about whether june 21st is
going to be
freedom day or not we're joined by the
government's
independent advisor on code and
ethnicity
dr raheb ali
dr ali do you think that progress
uh along the road map has now been
derailed
by the delta variant
uh good morning trevor and thank you
time on the program this morning
just before i answer that trevor i just
wanted to mention something about the
general approach that i've taken
you know throughout this pandemic as to
whether we should have
uh ongoing restrictions or lifting
restrictions and
the approach i've always taken is that
we have to look at the overall kind of
benefits and harms of a particular
policy and we're trying to minimize
overall heart so of course
you know there are potential harms from
covert if it's allowed to get out of
control in cases and hospitalization and
deaths increase but of course there are
also potential harms
from ongoing restrictions and over the
last 18 months i've consistently called
for restrictions generally to be lifted
earlier particularly last summer when i
felt that schools were closed
for too long and we could have reopened
sooner so having said all that
uh it's true that the situation has
really changed over the last two weeks i
mean two weeks ago when i was asked the
same question
i said it was just too early to tell we
needed to look at what data would
materialize over these two weeks but
unfortunately over the last
few days what has become very clear is
that case is because of the delta
variant which really has transformed the
situation
cases are increasing rapidly doubling
almost every week in some places but the
key factor is now the hospitalizations
are also increasing
fortunately not at the same rate as we
saw back in labels one on waves two
and but they are increasing uh
sufficient rate that we need to be very
cautious going forward
what would you like the prime minister
to say when he speaks tomorrow
it sounds like you think you would urge
delay
and if so for how long
so the reason i think a delay is
inevitable now is because as i said what
we're seeing now in hospitals
hospitals are extremely busy at the
moment the emergency departments last
month
where the business they have been you
know for years um because a huge
backlog of patients that didn't come in
during the the peaks
particularly the second wave partly
because they were worried about catching
covered and also because they didn't
want to put pressure on the nhs
so having a huge number of people coming
to the emergency departments as well as
dealing with this huge waiting list and
backlog
and so even a relatively small increase
in hospital emissions
for covid will have a significant impact
on all our non-covered patients all our
cancer patients heart patients etc
and we really can't afford you know to
for those people to suffer anymore
they've already suffered
enough over the last 18 months so what i
expect
the prime minister uh to say is that
based on that data
unfortunately a a delay is needed to
make sure
that we don't get to a situation again
where the nhs is unable to provide care
to all its patients i mean this this
slogan that we've had over the last you
know 18 months of protecting nhs it's
not about protecting hospitals or
doctors or workers here
it's really about protecting our
non-coded patients that's really the key
and uh that's what we need to ensure we
don't get into that problem again
and the second point really in essence
what you you're sorry
so carry on and it's okay um i was gonna
say the irreversibility really
is key as well as the prime minister has
stressed i think the worst thing for all
of us
and for the economy the hospitality for
our mental and physical health would be
to go backwards you know to
to re to go back to before we were
before step three at least with step
three we're able to visit
a family and friends and to me and to go
out et cetera
so the last thing we want is to have to
go backwards
do you think that there is any value
in for example closing schools at this
point
no certainly not i think children uh
have suffered
hugely over the last uh 18 months and
one of the main things i've always
stressed is that schools should stay
open as long as possible and i would
have wanted them to reopen earlier
last year but the other point related to
that is that if cases continue to
increase even without hospitalizations
that has a significant impact on the
number of children in school we saw in
bolton before half term
a third of children were off school and
certainly we don't want that happen
across the country
so by keeping cases as low as possible
in the coming four weeks while schools
are open
that maximizes the chance for all
children to be in school until the end
of term and you ask me about the amount
of time that's required for this delay
i mean partly because of schools partly
because of what's likely to happen with
the nhs
you know it seems that a four-week delay
would be optimal
it allows us to vaccinate millions more
people both with first and second doses
and the good news is that you know in
places like bolton we saw that where we
increased vaccination and testing and
people took
more care we were able to bring this
third wave under control and although
hospitals did increase
they didn't get as high as the the
second or first wave